yes
um
um
thank you
anybody get a knife
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
hmm
um
one more
um
thank you
this morning
well thank you for joining us this
morning
last night indianapolis was
revisited by the scourge of gun violence
that has killed far too many in our
community
and in our country
although we will learn more about this
case
in the coming days and in the coming
weeks
no piece of information will restore the
lives that were taken
or the peace that was shattered
nothing we learn can heal the wounds of
those who escaped
with their lives but who will now
bear the scars and endure the memories
of this horrific crime
what we are left with this morning
is grief grief for the families of those
killed
grief for the employees who have lost
their co-workers
and grief for the many americans
struggling to understand how tragedies
like this
continue to occur again
and again they joined the indianapolis
community
in trying to understand this senseless
violence
and it seems to me that
beyond the need of comfort for the
grieving
we must guard against resignation
or even despair the assumption that
this is simply how it must be
and that we might as well get used to it
we need the courage that compels
courageous acts
that push past weariness
i want to thank the first responders who
arrived
at the scene the iems
personnel who provided medical care to
those injured
and the brave impd officers
who responded and who are now
investigating
the events of last night
by all accounts these women
and these men acted heroically
caring for victims and families
and bringing order to a
chaotic environment
i'll close by saying this
community last night was a devastating
blow
and its impact will be felt by our
community
for days and weeks to come
in times of despair i know that
our residents will rally together
and help one another make it through
the eyes of the nation
are on indianapolis
today in ways that we
would never have hoped for
and for those who only know of this city
what they have learned when we are
hosting major events
on a global stage they would be forgiven
for simply believing that the people of
indianapolis
are known for kindness shown to those
who come to visit
what they cannot see in those moments
and what is difficult for us who live
here
to see in these moments
is that this spirit of generosity
and radical love is shared not just by
our residents
but between our residents
it is what makes this a special place
that we are proud
to call home in times of triumph and in
times of tragedy
it is what gives us the strength to see
through the darkness
and find the light of love that exists
within each of us
it is what gives us hope
and no crime of passion
or act of hate can take that away from
us
not today not ever
i'll turn it over now to the chief of
the indiana indianapolis metropolitan
police department
chief randall taylor
so this morning for the third time since
january our community woke up to news of
a senseless
crime that will not soon leave our
memory
this is unacceptable for indianapolis
our impd officers went towards danger
as they typically do and when they
arrived on the scene they found
something that really no one should see
we've all been shaken by this heinous
act
i will tell you the one thing that drew
me to indianapolis when i first came
here in 93
was for such a big city to have such a
small town feel and heart
our impd chaplains have been on the
scene
since early this morning providing care
and comfort
and support to the families of the
victims
my heart is broken over the lives that
were lost
fedex is a major employment employer in
this city
if you ask around there's numerous
people myself included that had family
and friends
that work for this great company and
they have built bonds
whether they work there for a short time
or a long time
can only imagine what the victims
the surviving victims and their
co-workers are going through
but we're truly with them
the crime scene remains active ipd along
with public safety partners
will continue to work at the scene
for as long as it takes to ensure a
thorough investigation is complete
you'll soon hear from deputy chief craig
mccart
who will share what we know to this
point but that information will be
limited
i can share a few things with you though
i know the first responders did an
incredible job
you more than likely will hear stories
of their bravery
as this develops i know it's going to
take time for us to
learn more about what happened last
night and i don't honestly know that
we'll ever really know
all the ins and outs to why this
occurred
but we'll certainly do our best
but i do know our community stands
together that was evident
through services that were rendered by
companies here like indigo holiday inn
and and also with our law enforcement
partners i'd like to thank personally
superintendent doug carter and state
police for their help
and also our other federal partners who
are always by our side
now i'll introduce one of those partners
fbi special agent
in charge paul keenan
thank you chief as the chief said my
name is paul keenan i'm the special
agent in charge of the fbi
indianapolis field office first and
foremost
i offer my sincere condolences on behalf
of the fbi
to the family and loved ones of the
victims of the senseless violence that
took place last night
while we mourn the devastating loss of
their lives we are dedicated to honoring
their memory through a meticulous
investigation
fbi indianapolis is part of this
community and we stand
with our friends and our neighbors to
condemn this violent act that has
impacted so many
i stand here today with my partners
because because whenever there is a
tragedy such as this
the fbi surges resources to assist our
law enforcement partners in addressing
those immediate needs
fbi personnel are assisting the crime
scene conducting interviews
assisting on the search of the suspect's
home and will provide
any technical expertise requested by the
impd
many of you have already asked what the
motive of this shooting was
and with less than 12 hours since the
shooting
it would be premature to speculate on
that motivation
i can tell you that there is no further
threat and updates will continue to be
shared as there are more details
we're grateful for our strong
partnerships with the law enforcement in
indiana
as we have done in other cases the fbi
will dedicate all available resources to
follow every lead
and use all investigative capabilities
to seek justice
and bring closure for the victims
families
next up i'd like to introduce deputy
chief craig mccarthy from the impd
thank you
good morning uh first of all i'd just
like to reiterate some of what's already
been said
recognize this this horrible tragedy
that our communities experienced this
morning
and certainly our condolences go out to
the
victims their families their friends
their loved ones
and our thoughts and prayers are
certainly with all all those who are
affected by this
this violence and and we know that
that's far-reaching that this violence
is
is far-reaching and so we keep all of
them in our
in our thoughts as we as we move forward
so i will quickly go through um
how this investigation has progressed
and again
um bear with me there's going to be a
lot that i am not able a lot of
questions that you may have after i'm
done that i may not be able to answer
we're still working on those answers
this this investigation is very much
still in its
infancy but i will answer what i can
after we're done so late last night
officers received
a run of shots fired to the fedex
facility
when officers arrived they found a very
chaotic and active crime scene they
found several victims
injured and several victims deceased as
well as the suspect
who was deceased as well of an apparent
self-inflicted gunshot wound
detectives were summoned to the scene we
began interviews with the many witnesses
that were that were on scene crime lab
responded and we began to to process
that crime scene and and that continues
now and and
we're still several hours from being
able to complete that at this time so
we're there's still a lot of work to do
out there
our victim assistance and chaplain's
office also responded to the scene
to assist uh with with the witnesses uh
victim families
and indigo was at the scene to help us
transport
uh employees witnesses and families to
the family
reunification site which was a nearby
hotel and so we continue to work with
those employees
and families as as we work through
identification
um and and speaking with those families
before i before i open anything
up uh for questions i i just want to i
want to recognize the work that's being
done out there
as we speak um by our detectives and the
help that we have received
um from from other law enforcement
agencies i'd like to
also give a thank you to the state
police um they were they were a huge
help last night as their detectives work
right alongside with ours
um they allowed us to use this facility
not only for this
for this event but for interviews last
night
indigo as i've already said are federal
partners who who have been right beside
us
throughout this investigation as well
we will now work alongside the coroner's
office as we work through
uh victim identification and um
and so we again just a big thank you to
to all those folks the victim assistance
unit the the chaplain's office um
you know we couldn't have we couldn't
have done this without the help that
that we've received
uh today and and certainly our crime lab
techs have been out there all night as
well
so if there are specific questions now i
will open it up for those questions
and again i will try to answer uh answer
whatever i can
i know
what can you tell us about the suspect
you know i can really tell you very
little and and
the reason is we are still working to
identify
everybody that is still on scene there
um so we we are not able to make
positive identification
of the suspect so there's really not
much that we can that we can say about
him until we have made positive
identification
did any of them say anything about the
suspect did they recognize this person
so what we did find preliminarily from
the interviews that were conducted was
that
um you know this suspect came to the
facility
and when he came there he uh he got out
of his car
and pretty quickly started some random
shooting
outside the facility there was no
confrontation
with anyone that was there there was no
disturbance there was no argument
he just appeared to randomly start
shooting
and that began in the parking lot and
then he did go into
the building uh into the facility for a
brief period of time
before he took his own life
we don't know that again um that's
difficult to
determine until we make positive
identification
so we're certainly working uh with the
fedex organization
um in trying to establish all those
connections but we just can't do that
yet
and that's that's accurate i mean we
have we have an idea
um we have some we have some other leads
that led us
to that location um but again until we
make
positive identification um along with
the coroner's office
we're we're not going to obviously
identify anybody
there's all kinds of things going on in
the investigation but yes that is one of
them
potentially
again the crime lab is still out there
collecting all that evidence and we
can't
determine those things until they've
they've completed
had any indication that perhaps this
trouble was
going to occur
no um you know we're still working with
with fedex security
um for for anything that um that might
have been an indicator that this was
going to happen but
right now we don't we don't have those
ties and again it's
rust is still very early still in the
infancy so we're still doing those
interviews we're still working closely
with fedex to find those things
to find those things out
yes my understanding is that everything
by the time that
officers entered um that
that the situation was over that the um
that the suspect took his life
very shortly before officers actually
entered the
facility
[Music]
you know it's hard to say exactly but
the estimates that that we have heard
or just a couple minutes that it was it
did not last very long
no we cannot confirm that yet how many
people were in the building at the time
uh you know what i i can't tell you that
that would be a question that the
that someone from the fedex organization
would have to answer i don't know the
number
um i don't know that number right now
so what we have right now is that there
were five that were transported from the
scene
uh four of those had suffered what
appeared to be
um non-fatal gunshot wounds and then
there was another injury of some sort
that was
a personal sort of injury that was
transported as well
several employees
no i think that i think that we were
contacted very quickly
uh once things started happening um now
what i have heard is that you know part
of the frustration
in family notification has been due to
you know a lot of these a lot of these
employees did not have cell phones as
they
flee the building and get transported to
other places there without their cell
phones and so they had a hard time
getting with family so that was
that was certainly frustrating for uh
for those employees as well as their
families
um we're checking for for surveillance
video and certainly
um you know one would think in a large
facility like that that
that at some point there's going to be
some video that we're able to obtain
[Music]
i heard that kind of anecdotally but i
have not heard that that was reported to
law enforcement
to this point now we're doing lots of
interviews still so i'm
it's not accurate but i have not heard
it from from people within my own
organization
[Music]
uh we haven't determined that yet but i
know uh there are some places where
i think a lot of the employees take
breaks and and lunches and things like
that out in that area as well so
and it could have been a shift change as
well i just don't have i don't have that
answer right now
the scope of the investigation
what are you collecting and then also
sir the follow-up question how many
people
have you done
so so first uh it's not just inside the
building where we continue to work and
process the crime scene because as i
indicated it it started outside the
building so
crime lab personnel uh have a
painstaking process
a very organized process of documenting
all the evidence that's there on the
scene
and that will start with diagrams and
pictures and videos and then the actual
physical collection
of any evidence that's on the scene so
that has to be done in
there's a big area like i said we
started outside and then we went into
the facility so
all that's going to take a while
well in response to the question i i
would uh point to the fact that just uh
last week
i signed on to a letter from over 150
mayors around the country
asking for the united states senate to
consider legislation that would expand
background checks to be required when
firearms are transferred
between private citizens
and to close the charleston loophole
which allows federally licensed firearm
dealers
to transfer guns to customers before an
adequate background check is completed
so the fact that i joined with 150 other
mayors in asking the
um the federal legislature to do that
um at least indicates
what i would like to see done
legislatively
my concern about the indiana general
assembly is
i believe they only have three or four
days left in
in this particular session
but i certainly uh will make it clear to
uh our governor and to legislative
leadership
uh where i stand on these
and issues conversation share with us
what was that conversation like as the
white house promised to offer any
services or resources
in indianapolis well as most people
know the chief of staff to the president
of the united states is a north central
high school grad from indianapolis
indiana so it was not at all unusual
that
he would reach out to me basically the
offer was
anything you need mayor we stand ready
to assist
um it was not a direct communication it
was just text messaging
and i of course responded thanking him
and
told him that we would uh keep him
uh made aware of the progress of the
investigation
and if the white house was able to do
anything to
support uh i'm certainly not hesitant to
ask
for
ask the it house what would what would
you need what what resources could there
be whether
the federal police and the other
agencies
well we're always we're always deeply
appreciative
of federal support whether that come by
way of dollars
uh or otherwise uh and frankly
uh the city of indianapolis uh is
grateful for example the
cares act provided 168 million dollars
many of those dollars went to our first
responders uh
last year uh according to the american
rescue plan um i believe
indianapolis may very well be receiving
over the course of the next two years
425 million dollars uh and i have no
doubt
although we have not made any decisions
about how to to utilize that money
i have no doubt that that money will
also be used for
law enforcement and first responder
support so
anytime washington uh makes the offer uh
we're
we're very grateful and uh certainly
inclined to accept
yeah i think that the community needs to
engage
uh in serious conversations and not just
our community but i think
conversations need to be held around our
country
and those conversations should be driven
by
the extraordinary proliferation of guns
and
cycles of violence that
in 147 instances already this year
have plagued communities around our
country and unfortunately for the city
of indianapolis
this is the third mass
killing that we have experienced so
the process of healing will take time
but i think
healing does depend on meaningful
conversations between people
about how we stop this
cycle of violence that's driven by
readily accessible guns and
i certainly intend to lead in that
regard
we've been told that the suspect
was allegedly shot to kill himself
so what weapon
[Music]
so we know that there was or we believe
that there was a rifle
uh involved we don't have the specifics
on the weapon yet as
again we're still processing that all
that hasn't been collected yet
um but we we do believe right now that
that
he had a
for rifle families that's still going on
right now and communicating with
families
um
and how long um
so i guess i hesitate to say typical
because thankfully we don't do this very
often and i'm sorry that we had to do it
today
um but but yes we do have our victim
assistance counselors we have our
chaplains at a nearby hotel
um which is which is where we took
employees to which is where we had
family meet them
obviously there are families who are
still trying to locate
loved ones and family members so we
continue to stand by their side
until such time when when we can either
locate those family members
or or identify them as a victim that we
have on the scene
way too early to yeah i mean we at this
point really it hasn't hasn't even been
touched as we still document everything
so
you know oh absolutely that's that's
part of
that's part of the scene so we're you
know we're
making sure that we have correctly
identified the car that we believe that
he showed up in and then absolutely
um i mean we will we will process that
as part of the crime scene
[Music]
um i so i believe that we had uh
four four outside
and then four inside plus the suspect
don't they have armed security inside
that i don't know have you been able to
identify
nothing gets moved nothing we don't
we don't check wallets we don't check
purses until everything is is
appropriately documented so i mean there
may be
some some fairly simple ways to identify
um and and we'll work with the coroner's
office to make sure that that's done
appropriate
appropriately with those families but to
this point we have we have not
identified any family of victims
of these people and for the suspect
um you know that might be a better
question
for the coroner's office because they
make that official identification
but i would think hopefully in the next
24 hours
that maybe we can do that
not i don't believe so
um when we came in here they were still
a couple hours away
so do you want to address that so before
you get the podium
what was happening at that time
i mean i think i know what happens but
what were those folks doing
before this happened you know again
that's a that's a question that
um that i'm probably not qualified to
answer that would be
best served to to ask the fedex
folks you know they have some different
facilities different things happen at
different facilities and i don't
specifically know
uh what what the folks inside here were
responsible for
how many people and how many hospitals
did you use
last night so like i said i believe we
had
five that were injured
and i can't say with certainty how many
different hospitals that
they went to um i know we had
i believe we had at least three but i'm
not certain of that
um and and i'll i'll let alfie blue um
begin to um i will let her address the
identification the victim identification
issues and if you have any questions for
her
good afternoon um on behalf of
the marion county coroner dr leandria
sloan
my name is alfarina mcginty and
we are in the process of conducting our
investigation
as has been stated what we typically
have to do is
wait until all of the evidence has been
collected
we are not able to go onto the scene yet
to confirm
any identities what we will do is we
will work with the victim's assistants
as well as the chaplains
at the identified location for the
families to reunify those families with
the decedents
we will utilize as much information as
possible that is on those decedents
that are at the scenes to make that
positive identification as you all know
indiana is very specific in how positive
identification can be done
which is identification by a family
member
dental dna and fingerprints and so
adhering to
all of those measures we must make sure
that the
people that are identified on the scene
are
accurately and appropriately positively
identified and so that process will take
a little bit of time
we have some information so far as to
what families are waiting
their loved ones to be identified or to
turn up somewhere and so we are going to
be working with those
families to efficiently and very
effectively
confirm the positive identification we
are still a number of hours
out before we are able to go onto the
scene
to conduct our investigation and then
after that we will work with the
families
following that process what we will have
to do is we will perform
our examinations we will be calling in
additional staff and so additional
resources will be available
or need to be available to us for the
additional staff
to be brought in for those examinations
to be done within the next 48
to 72 hours to confirm
the actual cause of the death
any other questions
i don't have the information
i i don't think there's anyone still
there but i
i can't say that for sure
[Music]
at this time we have not been able to go
onto the scene
to do any of that preliminarily what we
will do
is i will send information to the rest
of the
investigating team so that that
information can be shared
as we get updated information on
identities
age race gender and those things that
are important for
the family members and the community to
know
it is a very difficult job i've been
with the coroner's office for 23 years
i've not seen this capacity in terms of
the numbers of mass fatality shootings
in
a short period of time it is very
disturbing for our entire community
the staff is definitely suffering and is
going to
need long-term counseling with regard to
these types of deaths
it actually has you know we've had to
pull in
all of our 30 staff to conduct these
death investigations
and to work with the families because we
do still have follow-up information and
things that have to be done
and shared with the families it is very
time consuming
so it definitely takes a toll on our
staff and
again we are asking for additional
resources so that we will have the
capacity
to handle these types of death
investigations unfortunately
sure i don't do your job right so
the scope is pretty significant when you
have this number of people
um so pulling in all of our staff that
are available i'm calling people from
other jobs that have to come in and
assist as well as
surrounding county coroners that are
able to come in and assist us with these
types of investigations
additionally you know conducting we've
seen an increase in death investigations
in general
over the last couple of years and we are
trying to
work with our law enforcement partners
to understand and address these issues
that are causing this increase
in death investigations and so that is
something that our staff is definitely
has been working through over the last
two years to
be able to handle these things because
it is mentally draining
it is physically draining we are going
to work for
literally the next 24 to 48 hours just
to give
answers to the families our first
priority is to the families
and identifying with the decedent who
the decedent is as well as determining
the cause and manner of death providing
death certificates for those families so
that they can move on with their
information and things that they need to
do with regard to the loss of their
loved ones so our
our hearts um definitely go out to
those surviving family members that are
going to deal with this
lifelong
about tragedy if we can't identify the
suspect
and the victim can we say that everybody
is
okay has been identified reunited with
family members
and police
um i i think that's a safe assumption
but yet i can't say that
for certain um we think that that we
have
reunited families and workers and and
certainly all of those who
um who are have been treated to hospital
have been reunited with family um
but again i haven't been over over there
so i don't want to say for certain that
that's the case but i believe right now
that we have
thanks everybody
you